russia's invasion of ukraine is in its
second week some expected a quick
victory a moscow's objectives being met
and how far is the west prepared to go
in supporting ukraine militarily this is
inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fuli batibo it's been nearly two weeks
since russia's president launched the
invasion of ukraine vladimir putin vowed
to demilitarize and denaxify the country
and protect civilians he says have been
subjected to abuse by ukraine's
government in kiev now here's what's
happened so far the u.s based institute
for the study of war says russian forces
have taken these areas in red they
control the city of kerson in the south
mariopol and ukraine's second city
kharkiv have been shelled heavily
russian soldiers are trying to encircle
the capital kiev but ukrainian forces
have slowed their advance for now
russian units are reported to be
suffering from poor logistics and low
morale and they face strong resistance
from ukrainian soldiers al jazeera's
charles stratford reports from kharkiv a
city now in
ruins
a man walks carefully down a street
totally destroyed
russian bombs have ripped through these
buildings in central kharkiv
the area is silent and brutally scarred
shrapnel has ripped through cars
masonry thrown in the blasts has crushed
others
flames still rise from buildings nearby
bomb craters
and twisted steel
this street in central kharkiv shows you
just how devastating
the effect of russian bombing of this
city has been
an entire street
totally destroyed
many of these buildings
have people's homes in them
private residences flats some of them
still smoking
one of the main things that many people
here tell you
is that they can in no way understand
how the leader of a country like
russia
could do something like this
to a city
like kharkiv
tasa is in shock
she walks around in the days looking at
the destroyed businesses and homes
although you can use the cars
he went here
it's barbaric terrible the world is
shaking
i just don't understand
shrapnel has ripped through the golden
spires of an orthodox church
every window is smashed
underground metro stations is where many
people hide
young and old stand patiently in line
for food served by
a bowl volunteers
soup salad
bread
elona and her 12 year old daughter
nastia show us the train carriage where
they've sheltered since their home was
destroyed
it started 12 days ago our house was
destroyed
we don't know where to live anymore
i don't know where to go with my child
honestly help us
their belongings are neatly arranged
where they sleep
there are family pets here too
i thought we would live peacefully in
happiness united but i was wrong
[Music]
in another carriage we find 19-year-old
violetta and her baby son bogdan
he was born in hospital two days after
the russian army invaded
it's so difficult
every day we wash him upstairs
i'm so worried about him getting cold
vladimir putin told the world repeatedly
russia would never invade ukraine
kharkiv
is a terrified testimony to his lie
john stratford al jazeera
well russian president vladimir putin
insists the operation is going to plan
and says he won't call up conscripts or
reserve troops
i'd like to highlight that in the
military action no conscripted soldiers
will be taking part and we will not call
for reserves only professional military
personnel will take part in these
actions
and we will secure peace for all the
people of russia
and russia has titans reporting on the
conflict parliament passed a law
threatening up to 15 years jail for
anyone caught spreading what the
government calls false information
facebook is blocked tick tock and
netflix have suspended most of their
services
well let's bring in our guests now for
today's show in moscow pavel felgenhauer
who's a defense and military analyst
from oxford in the uk samuel romani
associate fellow at the royal united
services institute for defense and
security studies and from toulouse
france batiste hobart chief executive
officer of predictor lab an organization
focusing on fighting disinformation
gentlemen thank you all for being with
us today on inside story pavel in moscow
let me start with you some russian
analysts had said president putin had
ordered a victory
by march the second we're now mid march
and keith is still standing is the
conflicts going the way russia wants are
russia's war goals on track
well obviously not and not only in
russia there are such predictions uh the
pentagon was saying that ukrainian
organized resistance will most likely
collapse in 72 hours that means in three
days
and then of course there could be
guerrilla warfare but uh or the
organized uh
chain of command of ukrainian military
will collapse well it didn't
the ukrainians are still very much
fighting organized force their staffs
are working their chains command is
intact and actually right now i would
say we are at the crescent of this
conflict because uh
right now the russian advance has run
out of steam
obviously why is that
why has a russian military run out of
steam you think what have been uh the
hurdles and challenges for this military
well you know i would i could write a
big article about that because there's
still many things that went wrong and so
many things that were done wrongly by
the russian military and political
leadership i mean you can't answer it in
the science a sound bite
but the bottom line is
uh that they right now are advan began
advancing
in uh
directions uh
spreading out in different directions
they're not helping each other the
different parts of the russian operation
much well the ukrainians can use
operative lines from
inside to bring swing forces from the
north to south to
hit russian uh fight
military groupings uh
one by one
the so this is a i mean a textbook uh
for a military uh planning mistake a
very grave mistake somehow also the
russia russia has right now a very very
big
standing army a regular army of at least
170
permanent bat already battalion tactical
groups which is a lot but doesn't have
reserves right but on that point
president putin uh has said he won't
call up reservists but they've been
reports that they've already been
involved in this conflict what more can
you tell us about this
not really there is a small number of
new style reservists that are paid money
and are kind of could be used already
they're part of some units but they're
not many of them maybe 15
000 no more the rest are reservists that
are reservists only on paper they served
once
uh one year of compulsory service and
then were never called up for retraining
you have to call them up if you want to
call them up and then give them at least
four uh months maybe six if tr
retraining before they can be gone into
battle at least three i mean they can't
be used immediately so reservation
reserves with no military experience let
me just bring uh samuel romani into the
conversation i'll come back to you in a
second pavel for more on the russian
strategy samuel romani what is your
assessment of how the war is going is uh
putin's military objective
is it being met as he claims are they on
track
well i think the war is definitely
following uh
lagging well behind where russia would
want to be at this point because russia
was planning on a low-cost high-impact
operation that would lead to a quick
seizure of kiev ideally it wanted to cut
kiev off from the rest of ukraine
through the use of siege tactics and
through the use of a mixture of missiles
artillery bombings and also his other
objective was to landlock ukraine it's
achieved some of that objective by
getting control over the city of kurzan
but the mario pole corridor that links
crimea to the rest of ukraine still
remains an area of open conflict the
situation in northern and northeastern
ukraine also remains militarily stagnant
over the past 72 hours if the latest u.s
intelligence reports are to be believed
and that 60 mile convoy that's on its
way to kiev remains an open target
that's basically just uh stuck in
inertia right now how do you think the
ukrainian military has been able to
resist until now well the ukrainian
military has surprised many in part
because of the resilience of the
ukrainian air force that's been
something that many people have been uh
surprised by the united states has uh
says that the significant majority of
ukrainian air force planes remain intact
the russians have argued that most of
the core ukrainian air capabilities have
been destroyed but regardless we've seen
it remain a resilient force ukraine has
also used effective uh weaponry that she
that's received from other countries in
particular it's been effective in using
director tb2 drones from turkey but has
also been making good use of stinger
andy tank missiles and other anti-air
and anti-artillery systems that they've
received from western countries over the
past four weeks right okay let me come
to you now batist robert some estimates
by american officials claim that
ukrainian soldiers have killed some 3
000 russian troops
is this credible because there's a war
going on of course but there's also an
information war
it's i mean it's always complicated to
take uh the official numbers uh as
credible uh what we can say um in in in
what we can see on social networks and
what we can really verify
is that there is a huge number of uh
dead soldiers in both side for sure
and uh this is not as you said before
this is not the war uh
russia wanted to have uh this is not uh
happening as planned and this is uh the
same thing on the information
side for the information
and warfare we we are currently seeing
this is not something
well planned by russia and so this is
why they do have women would you say the
information war batista right now who's
winning the information war because
there's also been a lot of propaganda
from the ukrainian side
are the ukrainians winning the
information war
yes uh for sure in this first phase of
the war uh the ukrainian side is clearly
winning it because uh i mean they do
prepare some
some very good stories uh i mean
president uh zilinski is
pretty good at communication he is uh he
created his own persona his great uh is
right now like an error in in european
uh in
ukraine and for sure uh for sure they're
winning the fourth phase because russia
was not planned uh to have something on
on on the long term for sure and and
this is why on social networks at the
moment you can see a huge amount of
videos of uh pro
ukraine
videos
and uh you don't have so much um
propaganda so much cro russia uh content
at the moment i'll ask pavel in a minute
about how the war
i apologize uh for interrupting you uh
batiste but i'll ask pavel in a minute
how the war is being viewed uh in russia
within russia but first i want us to
compare the invasion of ukraine with
russia's previous military engagements
in 1999 russia invaded chechnya for the
second time in five years its stated aim
was to quash chechnyan armed forces
trying to establish an islamic state in
russia's dagestan chechnya's capital
grozny was leveled in the fighting in
2008 russia fought a 12-day war with
georgia moscow occupied the breakaway
regions of south ossetia and abkhazia
thousands of russian soldiers are still
there
six years later russia annexed ukraine's
crimean peninsula within a month and
began supporting separatists in the east
and russia's involvement in syria's war
from 2015 helped turn the conflict in
prison bashar al-assad's favor pavel let
me come to you now
when you look at the invasion of ukraine
and compare it to grozny for example
what do you think has hindered this
russian operation in particular was it a
lack of preparedness or
a lack of equipment
or morale being low among russian troops
as some have claimed
uh well it's always a in war it's always
a complicated picture and it's a bit of
every of all of that uh but i mean the
main strategic military mistake was that
in chechnya it was concentrated
offensive from the north from the east
and from the
west russian groupings were converging
on grozny
uniting forces in the end to take the
main uh point of enemy resistance in
ukraine they're moving in different
directions they're not converging with
each other it's i don't know they're as
if they're trying to i don't know corral
uh cattle or something they didn't
apparently believe that ukraine would
resist at all i it's hard to comprehend
how such an operation was produced in
the russian general staff but it wasn't
now we're stuck with it and the russian
pr machine is working very good inside
russia for the time being
but it will begin to falter because the
fact that russians advance has grind to
a stop is obvious we ran out of reserves
because we can't send
troops from other parts of russia
anymore because they're still preparing
if theirs will be an escalation into all
european or global war while ukrainians
are getting lots of reserves they're
mobilizing a total mobilization
so ukraine is getting stronger on the
battlefield and they're getting money to
fight this to get this effort then
they're getting lots of arms from the
west so ukraine right now in the
battlefields of ukraine on the ukrainian
battlefields is getting stronger and
russia is getting weaker and that's the
real serious problem there what do most
russians believe the presence of this
war what do most russians pavel believe
about what's happening across the border
the narrative that the kremlin is
putting out
the narrative the majority apparently is
taking it there's a rallying around the
flag uh thing happening right now of
course there are those who protest and
protest though they're being arrested
but that's maybe up to 30 percent of the
population maybe 30 percent of a fully
support actively this campaign the
others are rather indifferent but this
may change very quickly as western
sanctions tank the russian economy in
the coming months
to half a year the economy may so tank
that there's going to be internal
political repercussions
putin and his kremlin are right now in a
pickle
samuel romani in oxford comparing this
uh to previous russian engagements uh
whether in grozny or even syria would
you say the russian military has
underperformed during this invasion as
some western military analysts have said
well i think it certainly has
underperformed in this invasion so
that's definitely an area where one
would be concerned it's not just an
underperformance in terms of russia's
ability to exercise conventional
capabilities during the 2008 georgian
war there were a lot of problems with
supply chain shortages there were issues
connecting uh logistical and uh food and
other equipment between different
russian troops and different parts of
the conflict sergey shoigu is a defense
minister and vladimir putin vowed after
that conflict to modernize the military
and transform it and what it appears as
if russia's gotten is that they've
gotten a lot more sophisticated
technology in their military whether it
be higher grade hypersonic weapons or
the higher grade missile systems higher
great air defense systems but they
haven't figured out the core logistical
difficulties that undermine them inside
the georgian conflict
also it's important to keep in mind that
russia has been used to operations where
they have local proxies and surrogates
like in donetsk and luhansk in 2014 and
2015 the pro-russian separatists
militias or using air support with
ground uh backing like they've done in
syria they're not used to a large
terrestrial offensive of this kind and
their inexperience is starting to show
and finally the war has been a failure
also from the front of other
non-military means of offensive
operations like cyber security it
appears as if russia has been unable to
debilitate the ukrainian communications
infrastructures through cyber attacks
and they're now having to resort to
bombing them whereas russia has been
targeted by cyber attacks on numerous
occasions so it's been all around i
think a military failure all around a
military failure you say batista in
toulouse russia also used brutal tactics
to level grozny for example or even in
aleppo in syria uh during the civil war
but this invasion uh in
in uh ukraine and you know the the
leveling of kharkiv that we saw
in charles reports earlier it seems to
have resonated more with people in the
west in europe in particular why do you
think that is the this tour is a little
bit different from the others because
what we have to say is that uh at the
moment internet the internet is still up
on
on the large part of the of ukraine and
so a large
number of people do have a cell phone
and
film everything they can do
and uh
all these videos are available almost in
live on telegram on social networks and
this is the first one we can see which
is almost live live stream
live tweeted on on social networks on
this all these videos are analyzed
fact-checked and
you
have a large community of awesome
us internalists are people who
are doing uh open source intelligence
which are analyzing this video and are
able to verify everything uh almost in
life also this is super complicated to
live this is super complicated to push
from some propagand propaganda some some
disinformation so we still we are seeing
some attempt from russia to push uh to
create a trend around the seed as i said
this special operation we can see some
some operation from russia on the on on
some
very specific case for example you can
see some
uh some uh video bro who are miss uh
mislabeled some some false description
some stuff like this but as you said
um
the main the the main part of what we
you can see on the internet at the
moment
okay let me come to pavo because we're
almost running out of time pavel
president putin has threatened
you know invoking russia's nuclear
arsenal as a warning uh to the united
states and the west and its allies to
stay out of this war
how do you see this conflict evolving
now we're now in its
second week it's now in second week
where do things go from here
i believe the most probable way is going
to be a war of attrition
in ukraine and that's again not good at
all because
that will mean that the west supplies of
uh
war materials and humanitarian supplies
would be going over the border from
poland's iraqi and
romanians and hungary and that russia
would be saying that the war is
continuing because of those supplies
that has happened in many other wars in
algiers in vietnam and may begin
attacking the columns on the border or
maybe even attacking over the border and
that's already nato territory so there's
a possibility with the war dragging on
that there's possibility of escalation
happening there and that's the biggest
danger and that escalation could lead in
the end to a possible nuclear use samuel
romani in oxford sanctions alone haven't
been enough so far at least to make
president putin pause uh this invasion
can ukraine hold out on its own what
should western countries what can they
do uh to to support ukraine they've
ruled and ruled out a no-fly zone of
course but what are the options are out
there to give ukraine a fighting chance
well i think that the western countries
should really take action on some of
their military assistance pledges that
we've been talking about the european
union pledged 400 million 50 million
euros in terms of military assistance
and that included the deployment of
fighter jets so the deal that poland is
currently negotiating with the united
states with regards to mig-29 transfers
with the u.s filling in the polish air
force is a great step forward as would
be
similar deals coming from bulgaria and
slovakia that would allow the ukrainian
air force to target stationary russian
targets like the convoy that's on its
way to kiev so that's an important thing
also more deployments of anti-air and
anti-missile defense systems
particularly if russia starts emulating
his tactics in aleppo in kiev would also
be very helpful and more of support for
cyber infrastructure i think would also
be useful too like ukraine's uh
membership as an observer now and the
cyber nato deterrence unit is a positive
step and i think they should be more
integrated there too okay thank you so
much gentlemen for a very interesting
discussion pavel felgenhauer samuel
romani and batiste robert
and thank you as well for watching you
can always watch this program again
anytime by visiting our website at
aljazeera.com for further discussion go
to our facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can of
course also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
from me fully batty boy and the whole
team thanks for watching bye for now
[Music]